[Applause]
they're trying to shame the human race
by letting a nut cough in their face our
video of the day comes to us from the
world economic Forum or we where leaders
took a break from caviar and hookers to
discuss climate change and how it will
affect supplies of cavar and
hookers and Amazonian tribal Chief
closed the session in interesting
fashion roll it
Ricky
why why sh
[Applause]
[Music]
I
remember after a stranger in a headdress
kisses you and rubs spit on your face
put on your
mask you know it's a good thing we
didn't just experience a global pandemic
otherwise that kind of behavior would be
irresponsible but I haven't seen a
performance this compelling since I
watched Jesse Waters try to open a
revolving
door shortly after the indigenous Chief
finished her plea to heal the planet she
did what every climate change activist
did hopped in a private jet which
pulverized several flocks of endangered
geese you know what Tyrus do you think
this was all a prank she was just seeing
how far she could go to do she could
have done worse things no that would be
good yeah they took this poor woman flew
her out here probably without pay and so
she's going to come to this great thing
and talk about the needs of the Amazon
just we need you to do a little ceremony
for us then she did the ceremony and
this is the part she like wanted to
speak and tell people why she was there
they're like no we're
good and all that we really got from
that apparently the safe word for
everybody that weekend was yeah
so oh stop so again they just do this
crap yeah to try and they all s up there
oh look what I did look what I did I
took the breath from a a Native American
from Amazon like and then I'll guarantee
you 15 of them tried to order her from
Amazon that night
check their search history
FBI yeah it's like all those guys that
came there for the cocaine and the
orgies were like this isn't the blow I
had in
mind te is this the answer to the
climate
crisis here's a here's a question for
everybody does anybody know what she
actually said no right so we just know
her now forever as the coughing lady who
may have been for all we know spreading
Ebola and committing mass murder right
nobody has any idea in the world what
she was there for or what message she
was actually imparting to the world so
like a lot of these things it may have
seemed a good idea at the time it's
completely and utterly pointless it is
pointless and has made a mockery of this
poor woman where presumably back in the
Amazon rainforest that kind of thing is
a tribal ritual thing nobody would laugh
at it it would be taken very seriously
instead she's on comedy shows from here
to London to Sydney and I think that on
every level is ridiculous they we should
send one of our gender studies Majors to
the Amazon to return the favor Jim do
you think that was Ruth Buzzy I mean it
looked like a it looked like something
from Gilligan's Island I
exactly she sounds like my wife's out
the passenger window we're in the
drive-in it's just uh it's it's silly
and it's fun watching all these people
who are uncomfortable with it pretend
that they're not um nobody likes that
nobody wants their head held and you
know and the red the red stuff I mean
that awful I've seen that in the mirror
after a few days and you know you know
you know they're all covid mask Warriors
all of them EXA the kind of people that
would break you for not wearing a mask
and there they all are literally being
exploded on by some stranger maybe this
is Greta stromberg's
replacement she's getting older no one's
buying anymore what do you got yeah I
saw this woman in Amazon spits
on get her Carrie already got her yeah
you know so I just it just occurred to
me that I wonder if Jeff Bezos is there
and the Amazon lady could have done that
to the Amazon
owner I love her really yeah she's like
the ultimate girl boss are you kidding
she's like a religious leader I I get it
I'm listening okay what she saying well
it doesn't matter piers because every
single person on that stage is there
because they're ve a very powerful
person right and you're way more
powerful than a powerful person if you
can walk up to a powerful person and
go in their
face and like not only do they allow her
to do it but they sit there like yes
thank you yeah thank you she's the most
powerful person at the whole Forum yeah
it is funny because those people go
there for ego inflation
you know they go there CU they're rich
but they can't flaunt their Rich so they
use it this as a vehicle to advertise
their virtue and but it still allows
them to Proclaim their wealth and status
and then this lady comes in and spits in
their face I wonder if that's even part
of it or if she just improved that at
the end of it exactly like she was
having a great set and she it would be
great if she'd gone off script nobody
was expecting it rehearsal she never did
that she said to her friend she goes
watch this I'm going to
that's that's actually what she said in
the beginning I want a contest I get to
spit on a bunch of white
people and she will be booked every
virtue signaling sorry Pierce Liberal
Party this Christmas she'll be at yeah
she breathed on me and my eyes were just
wide open and everything is just I'm so
alert now and my new name is
ocelot all right up next the state
trying to embrace tourist from outers
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else